you're looking at a GameChanger in
Prosthetics the only one today using
electrodes implanted in the nerves and
to have sensation the developer of this
bionic system is speaking to us from
Ukraine where War has led to a crisis
there is more than 15,000 people with
amputations in the country let's walk
through every step needed to implant his
bionic arm into a patient bionic
basically means that is a combination
between biology and electronics but
traditionally prosthetic arms are pretty
low fi some are purely aesthetic made in
silicone but not functional then there
are functional mechanical ones powered
by a wire and a patient's own movements
you can think about the CLA or a hook
that can open and close and it has a
system of Gears like brakes for your
bicycle then you have fancy electric
prosthesis where a patient can control
the fingers independently via electrodes
placed on the surface of the skin but
how do you keep the arm in place this is
normally done with the socket something
that is on your skin putting a lot of
pressure it's uncomfortable and heavy so
that that's why the first step in
installing Dr Ortiz Catalan bionic arm
is oio integration or implanting a
titanium structure directly to the
skeleton no integration made a a Big
Splash in the medical field the first
application were dental implants
eventually scientists applied this to
Prosthetics after discovering in the 50s
that if you attach titanium inside bone
the bone cells can grow directly on the
titanium making a very strong attachment
to the residual limb say you have a
transhumeral amputation above the elbow
the surgeon will place a titanium
implant that looks like a screw inside
the center of the bone and you leave it
there for a few months in that period
the bone cells grow around the titanium
implant and then you place a portion of
the implant that comes out through the
skin and that's where you're going to
connect your prosthesis implanting into
a residual limb that has been amputated
below the elbow has its own challenges
because there are two smaller Bones the
radius and the ilna and they move
independently from each other so they
will move like this they will move like
this this and they will also move in
their own axis so we develop an
artificial joint that allows for those
movements to take place while preserving
a natural orbit for the movement now the
next step is to surgically implant the
electrodes inside the body we will place
electrodes in the muscles and the nerves
around the residual limb electrodes on
the surface of the skin are susceptible
to electromagnetic interference stuff
all around us like tools or computers
can create noise interference radiating
to the El elodes if they're merely
sitting on the surface of the skin this
will cause the prosthetic to become
uncontrollable even just moving your arm
around can throw off a conventional
sensor if it lifts a little bit it
generates this what's called a motion
artifact if you move too fast if you
sweat the prosthesis become less
controllable with electrodes implanted
directly inside muscles on nerves you
don't have any of those problems if you
have an amputation where the hand is
gone you have many muscles here that
help you to control the fingers of the
hand so there's a lot of sources that
you can use to drive the prosthesis but
in the case of an amputation above the
elbow you don't have as much to work
with so the team has to get creative and
rejigger the body's original biological
wiring you have the biceps and the
biceps has two heads so it's not enough
information that we can extract from the
muscles to drive all the missing joints
so a solution for that is you can take a
nerve that used to go to the hand and
then you transfer it into one head of
the biceps so then when the patient
thinks about closing the hand this part
of the muscle will contract the short
head there are three big nerves in the
arm the radial the oler and the median
which allows you to control these three
fingers basically a nerve is a
collection of axons which are bundled
into fases so if you think about my
fingers as the bundles of the nerve what
you can do is split them you take one of
those bundles to connect with that
muscle that is available there and then
for the other ones we can borrow a piece
of muscle from the legs it's called a
free muscle graft and then we transfer
that to the arm to connect to one of
these facles next you insert a metal
electrode into the muscle and connect
that to the conector inside the titanium
implants so it has a wire and that wire
is covered by materials are
biocompatible meaning that they're well
taken by the body the signals that come
from your brain to control your limbs
travel through nerves but these organic
signals are relatively weak about 10,000
times smaller than the strength of the
signals generated by these new electric
plugs so in a way the implanted
electrodes use the muscle like a
loudspeaker amplifying the signals from
the brain to the muscles and to the
prosthesis the implantable part has no
batteries all the power happens in the
prosthesis you can think about it as a
USB port into the nervous system The
Next Step involves training the AI in
the bionic hand CPU to understand what
the signals from the brain mean the way
we control our limbs is by electric
signals coming down through the nerves
to the muscles and these come in the
form of electric impulses those signals
are captured by the electronics of the
prosthesis so they travel down to the
prosthesis where there is the brain of
the prosthesis understands what those
signals are but that CPU in the
prosthesis doesn't automatically know
what those patterns of activation mean
the AI needs to be trained what we do is
we tell the patient try to close your
hand and then we record signals and then
we say try to open your hand and we
record the signals and then the team
labels that action for the AI
translating neural signals from the
brain into code that is now understood
by the tiny computer in the prosthetic
arm which then engages its robotic
motors to move in specific ways the next
step involves training the patient using
software this was actually the first
time we saw the patient after the
surgery we connected it to a virtual
reality system those two cables coming
out of the implants are sending signals
wirelessly to the computer where they
are interpreted and used to control a
virtual limb this trains the muscles and
makes the signals more distinct and
reliable in preparation for when the
patient gets their bionic limb but this
training also addresses another
challenge that arises from amputation
after you have an amputation there's
pain that remains from something called
Phantom limb pain which is caused by the
brain getting confused and imagining
that the missing limb is frozen or
twisting in awkward ways so I developed
some technologies to treat Phantom limb
pain we coupled those with virtual and
augmented reality so the patient can
engage the same neural resources that
were used to control the hand this helps
them reduce their pain this training is
useful in fine-tuning the algorithms
that will drive the robotic Motors but
working in the virtual world is one
thing without their bionic arm attached
patients will do relatively well because
there's no load so the final step
involves fitting the prosthesis and
testing in the real world patients come
into the lab put on their bionic arm and
perform daily tasks like packing a
suitcase or picking up small objects
these are tasks that can tell you a
little bit about the function the
patient has with the prosthesis the team
then makes adjustments and runs further
tests that evaluate and help improve one
of the most jaw-dropping features of the
prosthetic its ability to feel objects
in its grasp when the prosthesis make
contact with the object there are
sensors in the the fingertips and then
the brain of the prosthesis has also a
neuros stimulator which delivers
electrical pulses to the nerves and
because the brain receives this data
from a nerve that used to be connected
to the biological limb it will interpret
it as coming from the bionic hand if I
have a biological receptors in my index
finger that has a nerve that goes all
the way up to my brain if I put an
electrode along that nerve it doesn't
matter where I stimulate the brain will
create the sensation that's coming from
the fingertip so now automatic Sensation
that rises in Consciousness the bionic
hand uses sensors in its thumb and index
finger to send an electrical signal
through the prosthetic and then along
the original severed nerves straight to
the brain but the information from the
fingertips is not as nuanced as what a
biological fingertip feels for us we
have hundreds of sensors that travel in
hundreds of neurons today we don't have
that resolution at the neural interface
we're still a long way off from the type
of sensation seen in the artificial
limbs in Star Wars this hand only
provides provides rough Sensations but
they're still useful because now a
patient can feel when there's an object
in their hand and if that object is
slipping away but what about batteries
they have to power the CPU and the
motors that drive the prosthesis right
you can have interchangeable batteries
and whenever the the prosthesis run out
of battery they just switch it a battery
will normally last a full day it's very
much like our phones everything is
self-contained so the days of patients
carrying heavy backpacks full of
computers or bulky batteries are gone
these days Dr Ortiz Catalan really only
sees patients a couple times a year when
something breaks or if he needs to
fine-tune anything but these high-end
bionic hands can come with a price tag
of over
$110,000 but hopefully like any other
technology more is available the less
the cost will be we created a human
machine interface which means we can
connect the prosthesis or we can connect
to your steering wheel of your car and
you can drive it by thinking about
movement of the wrist you can integrate
it to whatever your imagination wants
cool so can we make humans stronger
cyborg style there will be companies
that think about human augmentation
making a human jump higher run faster
carry higher loads you can have one
prosthesis that much stronger than a
human hand but you cannot have a
prosthesis that is as dexterous as a
human hand that's something that we
haven't achieved from the robotic side
personally I got involved in prosthetic
devices because I wanted to solve
problems and I'm in the business of
bionic medicine there's so many problems
out there that have not been solved when
it comes to disabilities that I feel
that is more important that we focus on
that